all right it shows that we are live
hello everybody happy Friday I'm Jimmy
corsetti my channel is called bright
insight and if you haven't seen my video
that I made uh about this time last week
involving the Thousand ton stones that
the Egyptians inexplicably moved
hundreds of miles this is going to be
kind of a rehash of that answering
questions as well as looking at the
notable comments uh surrounding this as
well as addressing other little things
that have come up of people trying to
explain what could have been done so
this is going to be a fun conversation
it's obviously big weekend uh to
everyone that celebrates Christmas Merry
Christmas um but yeah I want to go out
this for a good hour today so I'll be
paying attention to the chats as best as
I can and I want to see what kind of
great questions you guys have let me
just make sure everything's up on
both we are live on both right now yep
we are good to go super chats are
welcome today I'll definitely be keeping
a look on those and as more and more
people filter in in the next few minutes
I'll really start hammering in the point
uh but so those of you that already
watched the video what were your
thoughts like I included multiple
different uh examples such as the two
720 ton colosia mnan statues they were
transported over 300 possibly 400 miles
from Cairo to where they are now in
luxer um 720 tons a piece carved from
one single piece of stone and then I
included the Thousand ton ramum statue
that was moved at approximately 150
miles and it's one of the largest Stones
ever cut in in modern human history uh
how do they do this because as you saw
in my video uh is that I included the
example of the 340 ton stone that was
moved in 2012 to the Los Angeles County
Museum of Art where they custom built
this trailer and to those of you who
haven't seen I'm be showing photos and
images in this uh live stream so you'll
see what I'm talking about but they had
custom build this trailer 260 feet long
32 feet wide 196 tires attached to 44
axles and it took them 11 nights moving
four miles an hour and it was a year of
planning from start to finish till they
executed the project it's like okay so
it kind of puts into perspective that if
the Ancients were moving something
that's three times as heavy as that well
how the heck did they do it right so
thank you everyone for tuning in um
again I'm gonna be keeping a close eye
on these chats I want to be able to
answer good questions um yeah people
already talking about boats yeah well
they would have moved on the
Nile what Egyptian barge or boat could
have lifted a thousand tons and what
would have what physics would have went
into lifting that type of weight on and
off the boat there is no evidence that
he had that kind of capability um they
surely did move stones on the Nile this
is documented that uh Diary of mayor's
receipts lists that there was Limestone
blocks brought to Giza but the thing is
that was brought from the Torah quy
which is like eight and a half miles
away and there are millions of Limestone
blocks in the Giza Plateau that are
small insignificant compared to the ton
Stones remove 500 miles into the Great
Pyramid of Gea hundreds of feet up not
comparable um so someone said what's
rounds Jimmy's neck it's just a shirt um
does it look like something around
me um let's see here give me one second
make sure everything's on the up and up
on these chats Jimmy Canadian no I am
not this is Christmas spirited chur uh
look it's red it's got pop fact I feel
like in the camera it doesn't look as
red as it is in real life this thing
pops it is kind of Canadian mountain men
though isn't it um so let's see here all
right how many people we got in here
people are filtering in right
on double check on
Rumble all right awesome we got people
tuning in all right everybody so this is
the thing and uh let's see we already
got an A Super Chat let's see here from
Mr Avatar standby so Jimmy have you ever
heard of Dr Stone the premise of the
series is very similar to many you
promote and it's done in 2019 being
ancient history to the people 3,700
years in the future I have not what
platform is that on um I'm gonna have to
check that out Dr Stone that sounds like
it's right up my alley someone says
looking sharp Jimmy thank you from
Arizona hello from Brazil someone said
yo I want this shirt so got on this
website uh it's called B bonobos.com
it's it's a men's designer brand and
this thing is awesome it's real soft
I've had it for over a year now I've
watch worn it a number of times usually
around holiday season I like this thing
it's soft as hell I recommend um okay so
let's see here yeah ask me some
questions I'm gonna be diving into this
stuff and I want to hear what people
think of what I discussed and I'm going
to be getting into the so-called not the
so-called the Thunderstone of Russ
Russia back in the late 1700s they moved
an alleged 1500 ton block which became
lighter as they carved it down along the
way and a lot of people say well if they
could do it this is how the Egyptians
must have done it um to those of you who
aren't familiar with this thing one it's
believed that the weight of that was
grossly exaggerated on Grim Hancock's
website there's an article someone made
breaking down the math and the estimated
at 400 tons and that would make more
sense to me because when I see the size
of it and I compare it to the size of
stones at bulbeck which are a thousand
tons I'm like no I don't think so I
don't think that's the weight at all not
even close but regardless they moved it
on ball bearings and iron
sleds and on a track and it took them
nine months to move it 3.7 miles it's
not comparable and because the Egyptians
are a Bronze Age culture whereas you
know the Russians in late 1700s that's
Iron Age there's a distinct difference
so we're talking about what the
Egyptians could have done as a Bronze
Age culture this based on what we were
taught in school right this is where it
gets fun because people like what about
the Thunderstone what about the
Thunderstone and this assuming it even
was 1500 tons it's like sorry but the
Egyptians didn't have iron sleds now did
they and I would like to see a two
million plus pound Stone be supported on
top of wood sleds I don't think so right
um so this is the fun stuff let's see
here we got Mona I'm so happy to see you
back on YouTube thank you so uh I've
been seeing a lot of the feedback people
although a lot of you guys like my live
streams a lot of people like hey Jimmy
want these typical presentation that you
do so I'm grinding those back out I'm
working on a deal with Rumble right now
to be able to promote more of those
types of videos because I'm saying hey
I'm having fun with the live streams but
I feel like this isn't what I'm best at
and I feel like what my following wants
most is my typical presentations so I've
got a second wind on that I'm already
working on my next video I'll I won't
tell you the topic because this is
something I've been sitting on and it's
good um but that'll be done before the
end of the year that's all I'm gonna be
working on between tomorrow I'll have a
day off for Christmas with family and
stuff like that but um I'm going to be
hammering away at that and it's time to
just grind grind grind and make at least
a couple videos killer videos a month
like I like I used to um so look forward
to that I'm excited about it um let's
see here let me keep looking at these
chats because I really want to be able
to do super chats and like be
interactive with you guys on this
particular day I'm not bringing any
guests on and I just want to kind of
have fun I if I sound sick I'm already
getting better uh I woke up Tuesday
morning like super freaking achy chills
headache and I was like that until
yesterday and I woke up today feeling
much much better I'm just slightly tired
I've actually feel pretty good now
little bit of fleem in the morning got
to cough it up kind of gross but like
man the last few days I don't know what
it was but it hit me like hard um but
I'm strong I I bounce back quick um all
right so let's see here someone said Dr
Stone is Anime I'm not into the anime
scene it's hard for me to watch cartoons
and animation stuff but I'll check out
this St Stone
stuff um yeah don't worry they're
putting vaccines in your food now it's
true I think it's
true dop up them farm animals with it
all right let's see here I want to dive
into this stuff what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna read off for my sponsor here in a
second as soon as I'm done
coughing excuse me it's a tickle in my
throat okay we got Sara Rene
X so I was excited when you shared
Atlantis and the Sahara desert but what
if all the Earth is Atlantis especially
since all the technology was everywhere
here and slowely um we're uncovering our
lost history so I actually identify with
that my friend Nikki from the Nikki
channel was time but consistent globally
and I'm with I'm with that like I
actually think that makes the most sense
when I look at the the Lost uh um
history of South America and how it's so
closely to whether it's Japan and Egypt
or these polygonal stones
although I do think that the eye of the
Sahara matches this crazy description of
a city of concentric circles so to me
I'm like the eye of the Sahara is
something and that needs study and
that's something that I'm like it seems
to make sense if there was this lost
capital city that's got to be the place
but the the search doesn't end there
like I I really and I've made other
videos on this that I believe that
ancient humans were a global
civilization and that there are
signatures that are seen of stonework
that are seen across the continent in
the oceans thousands of years before
that that was supposed to be possible
from we were taught in school so I'm I'm
with that um excuse
me okay let me real quick I want to read
off my sponsors knock that out real
quick now that some people have tuned in
and then I'm gonna focus in on the rest
of the video so real
quick press a little button
here all right all right guys
so today's sponsor is Bur gold let me
read this off to you real quick
diversify your savings with physical
precious metals while stockpiling silver
in your home safe it's Birch gold
group's most popular special of the year
now through December 22nd for every
$5,000 you spend with Birch gold they'll
send you a 1 ounce silver eagle coin for
free visit birchgold.com bright insight
to claim your eligibility now you can
purchase gold and silver and have it
shipped directly to your home or have
Birch gold precious metal specialist
help you convert an existing Ira or 401K
into a tax sheltered
for in gold for no money out of pocket
and they'll send you free silver for
every $5,000 you purchase keep it for
yourself or give something with real
value as a stocking stuff for this year
just visit Birch gold.com bright insight
to claim your eligibility with an A+
rating a better Better Business Bureau
and thousands of happy customers now is
the best time to buy gold from Birch
gold visit birchgold.com bright insight
to claim your eligibility for free
silver on qualifying purchases before
December 22nd it ends today that special
deal so go and check them out and when
it comes to Gold guys with this e
economic situation we in right now
especially with 401ks and IAS you got to
back it up with something and when I
look at stock China stockpiling gold and
I look at the incredible value of gold
in India which India has the world's
largest population um and they are so
into gold out there it's a cultural
thing it seems to me that like gold is
the one safe thing to be invested in in
these times so I'll just leave it at
that um
but let's see here let me double check
on some the comments here and then I
want to dive right back into talking
about this video stuff um Mona n
planning any more trips to Egypt not at
this time I might be looking into doing
a trip to India uh in January of next
year I'm working out some details with
that I'll keep you guys posted I'm a
little iffy right now because I'm like
planning things out a year in advance
when this world is so crazy is hard for
me to stomach so for me to promote a
tour when it could be in jeopardy six
months from now because this world's so
crazy it gives me an uneasy feeling but
at the same time it's like I don't want
to sit around waiting for the world to
end when it doesn't end and then I could
have traveled and met interesting people
and documented the most amazing sites on
earth right but as far as um someone
said why India oh my God look at the
Lost history of India this will be one
of the topics I'll be diving into coming
into 2024 because we hear so much about
Peru we hear so much about Egypt but
India has some of the most spectacular
sites in ancient prehistoric history I
mean there is things carved out of stone
that will blow your mind if you're not
familiar people in the comments let
these people know about how crazy
ancient India is if you're familiar um
someone just said Co ruined my Tokyo
trip so that's another thing so I'm
looking to make a trip to Tokyo to
document some of their sites as well and
I want to knock that out real soon in
the next few months so I'll keep you
guys posted um what's good my ninja
thank you drek um so let's see here I'm
looking for comments let's see here I'm
toggling between YouTube and Rumble
because we're live on both of them right
now so bear with me but um what I really
want to hear from you guys is what your
thoughts are in this video that I just
made um I mean I have been if you're
following me on Twitter X or Instagram
and if you're not I encourage you to
especially Twitter I mean Instagram is
such garbage they censor they they but
I'll use them for now you know what I
mean like it's like in my line of work
you kind of have to have a social media
presence I mean not on Facebook even
though Facebook owns Instagram so it's
one of the same at this point but
anyways as I was I've been really
blasting out over the last couple months
saying like how did the Egyptians move
80 ton Stones 500 miles away into the
king's chamber in Grand Gallery uh 300
feet up and so I was kind of leading
into that because I knew in the back of
my mind I'm like that's not the most
impressive thing they did yes Moving 80
ton Stones 500 miles and lifting them
hundreds of feet above ground level and
stacking them
is unbelievable for what we think we
know about the capabilities of the
Egyptians but then when you get these
720 ton statues the colon and then
thousand ton statues such as at the
ramum they removed 100 miles see this
right here goes into the realm of like
calling the the known laws into physics
and I mean by that as far as let me
rephrase that actually it calls physics
into question from the standpoint that
when I'm going to show you what and as I
showed my video and I'm going to show
you pictures uh in this live stream here
in a moment um when it takes would it
took for us to move a 340 ton Stone in
recent times it's like it's these kind
of examples that give a proper
perspective on just how insanely heavy a
thousand tons is um so let me with that
being said let me bring up some of these
pictures here I just want to make sure
I'm not missing any good questions all
right so hold on seconds let me bring
this stuff
up and I'm going to show you this 340
ton Stone all right here we
go here we go all right one second hit
this I need to have a producer helping
me manage this stuff right okay present
share
screen one
second all right I'm going to share the
window entire screen
share okay make sure this is
working all right let's make sure you
guys see
this y'all see this let me double check
yes you do all right so this is an
article here this is 2012 the 340 ton
Stone moved 106 miles to the Los Angeles
County Museum of Art it was called the
largest operation of its kind since the
Egyptians built the
pyramids cost 10 milli million dollar
and this thing this Stone right here
this is a work of art in case you needed
to be reminded and it's called levitated
Mass because as you can see they tried
to design it to make it look like it's
like hovering or something I'm
sorry okay I think it's dumb I think
it's such a waste of money but I'm so
glad they did it so we could have a
proper example in modern times of what
it takes to move something of such
incredible weight 340 tons and it took
yeah 21t
uh stands 21 feet high um 32 feet across
and okay this source is wrong about a
294 uh lengthlong trailer it's actually
260 but 196 wheels cost a 10 million to
move let's see here hold on De with me
196 Wheels 44 axles and all right so
here's the deal they had to build this
thing custom around the original
location at the Cory of the stone so
like they had to bring all this out here
custom built this whole big rig look at
this thing this is what we're talking
about 260 ft long nearly 200 Wheels to
move 340
tons look at these pictures this is so
epic and I remember seeing my video I
got all kinds of awesome comments people
are like delivery drivers say I saw this
I saw this one was happening they were
closing down the roads and they Sur they
did um look at this project Tim move
1340 ton Stone so when we look at
examples like this and then I'll talk
about this in a second let me back out
one second so you can see what I'm
talking about so if that's 340 tons then
when it comes to the 720 ton colasse of
mnon which yes both were carved out of
one single piece of stone the one on the
right was heavily damaged and later
reconstructed in fact apparently the
Romans did reconstructive work on it too
um the one on the left is obviously
damaged but it's far more easier to see
that it's what out of one piece of stone
and here I'm citing my source here
encyclopedia 720 tons each both carved
from one single block of sandstone look
at these suckers pictures don't do it
justice I've seen them in person they no
longer let you stand next to them so you
have to find really old photos um but
when you do compare it to people you
know what I mean the pedestal itself is
smaller than you know people and
men look at that 60 feet tall or 18.3
meters pictures do not do it justice
it's one of those things you'll hear me
say it a million times but these things
are absolute behemoths I did find some
photos in modern times of them doing so
restorative work on it and so you comp
it to a grown man look at that look at
this guy not even half the size of the
lower leg these things look at this
barely taller than the
ankle absolute behemoths and not only
that most of the pedestals are still
buried under the Earth and that's not
even part of the stone the pedestals I
heard are estimated at something like
300 tons assuming that that's correct
but within the hundreds of tons no doubt
more than 100 tons uh maybe 200 tons
it's hard to say but in the in the realm
of hundreds of tons most of it you can't
even see because it's merged beneath the
Earth and so when you realize that these
are literally more than each one of
these by themselves are more than double
the weight of that 340 ton stone that
they went to all that undertaking to
move and look you know science 720 tons
because some people say that's a gross
exaggeration they're not 720 tons I've
seen comments like that I'm like okay
well here's your scientific journal that
says so and that they removed from Cairo
Aquarian Cairo more than 300 miles as
the bird flies or nearly 400 miles by
road so quite interesting right so I
point that out and then we go over to
the
ramum which is a thousand ton Stone
that's now broken uh there's me standing
next to it I'm 5 foot 10 or 178
centimeters to anyone that's curious
look at the foot and one of the
questions I had when I'm seeing this
this statue and again you see it with a
grown man on top of it that's Doug I
went to Egypt with him great guy um it's
still doesn't do it justice like what
you see with your eyes in person and in
all these pictures I'm taking an ultra
wide lens like a $800 camera lens to be
able to get the whole one picture but it
distorts it and that like like oh okay
I'm not sure how big that really is but
when you stand next to it even with
these photos and you're seeing like okay
it really is Big the top of the foot is
up to my belly button but when you see
it with your own eyeballs it's a whole
different animal it's just like whoa but
the question I have is why is this thing
broken down in Smither let me show you
the aerial shot of it this is what it
used to look like was a seated statue
over 60 feet tall um wide as
hell and yeah thousand tons that's
according to the University of Chicago
prestigious School uh for ancient
Antiquities um this is me showing an
example of how much 60 tons is we keep
going by it um let me back out of here
so I can show you other stuff I was
going to lend your eyes to and the other
thing is so the because I'm such a nerd
I like looking this stuff up the world's
most uh heaviest Ultra let me reward
this um the biggest Ultra Hull truck in
human history is this bad boy the bellaz
75710 this thing can move 496
tons look at this thing the highest
payload on Earth the tires themselves
are 13 and a/4 feet tall you have to go
two up two flights of stairs just to
reach the cockpit look at this
thing this thing has eight tires and
I've seen some sources ranging from
$60,000 a piece to $99,000 a piece per
tire eight tires you compare it to a the
largest bull African elephant which are
at 13 feet tall and this thing is is
right about that same height look at
this yeah see $60,000 but then I see
another source for
9,880 per tire there's eight of them 496
tons so in other words that 1,00 ton
statue of the
ramum this thing could only lift half of
that weight the world's largest highest
capacity payload truck on earth and I'm
not saying they would use a dump truck
to move something like that but it it
just paints us a picture of the insane
amount of weight that we're talking
about here and it would be equivalent
that thousand ton statue is equivalent
to the weight of eight of these bad boys
mrun room stanks um so real quick let me
uh just go to my let me just end the
screen for a second okay so let me just
double check I want to see what comments
you guys have for me at this time let
make sure I haven't missed any super
chats thank you so much BMW
x3m um Drex says can we raid the
Egyptian tunnels like screw it let's do
it also you got to have some brass balls
call these fools out Westside get the
money oh that's funny um I am not going
to encourage any type of uh rating of
anything but you know if enough people
went down there and
you know stop you from going through
some of those Gates but that's the thing
if you go in Egypt there's so many lock
Gates all over the place so that kind of
raises some questions um let's see here
yeah what questions you guys have
involving this stuff because this is
just to me I'm like this is just too
much fun all right let me check my
Rumble
chat see here all right let's see one
tire is like 30,000 USD okay so on their
website say $60,000 and then that other
website said 999,000 I don't know that's
an older quote but straight from the
actual manufacturer from baz they they
said it was $60,000 to pop so if you can
get the hook up in that $30,000 let's
see who is a Elemental
gaming and even if that's the case so
eight times three you know holy crap you
know
$240,000 for for those or if it's 60,000
you know and then or if it's 99,000 so
it's anywhere you know upwards of
possibly $800,000 for all new
tires more like 400,000 though
if that's the case being $60,000 each or
so wild stuff uh yeah get bring the
Laura coft on my next Excursion you
bet um let's see
here I want to answer a lot of questions
on this this will make it a lot of fun
hey Jimmy hooked up on your pod from
London right on thank you
Birkin Jimmy do you believe the Hall of
Records was opened or still buried dude
I don't know that's a really good
question I think that there are
absolutely underground tunel well there
are underground tunnel systems in Egypt
uh the question is was there a labyrinth
and and people hundreds of years ago
were writing about a labyrinth
underneath the Giza Plateau um so yeah I
mean whether if the if the hall records
was there man that has been
explored I think um because what do you
think the powers of be would be doing
nowadays and they've done so many things
in the DL in
Egypt it's hard to know thank you so
much Jersey Devil love the the show I
appreciate that um let's see
here seey Jimmy when are you going to do
a collab with the Y files hopefully soon
I love AG guys the Y files is my
favorite channel that guy is killing it
he's doing all the best he's doing all
the the the the best topics and doing
the best job explaining him he does deep
Dives he's doing proper research he's
getting clarification I'm learning
things from him if you're not subscribed
to Wi files I highly recommend it's so
engaging the way he does it it's just
awesome he's really got his on that and
like he's killed it he's over three
million subscribers completely killing
it the guy inspires me if I'm being
honest all right productive thing humor
me have you ever speculated about the
possibility of gravity naturally
changing throughout history allowing
that we could not see as impossible as
being possible actually yes I do wonder
if the size of bir has expanded in fact
I bet you that it has can't prove it but
if that's the case would that have an
effect on
gravity I would think so I don't know
exactly how gravity Works um that's
still kind of a mystery a mystery in its
own way I mean you can measure it but
like it is kind of uh there are some
Mysteries involving uh gravity but
um like when I look at like the time of
the dinosaurs how big everything was it
does make me wonder Earth was smaller
and because of it the gravity was
lighter I don't know that that sounds
wild to some people but I entertain it I
wonder I don't know I'm not pushing the
concept of that but I do Wonder these
things BMW x3m again Jimmy
uh please do a video on a aant cave in
India aant caves are older than Egyptian
Pyramids let me double check which ones
you're referring to because the name
doesn't look familiar but I do
know um about caves in India so let's
see if these are the same ones I'm
thinking about oh yeah yep these things
are absolutely amazing let me bring this
up so everyone can see it in the chat
one second all right let me know you
guys could see this all right carved out
of Stone these are what you see here is
completely carved out of just not just
one piece of stone but out of a cave out
of out of a mountain look at that
actually not hit that be annoying and
let me just show you like like ancient
let's see
India ancient site and there's just so
many different things to see like
everything just out of what like right
here that's out of one solid piece of
stone amazing and in the details of it
is
spectacular India is a lost gold mine
for for ancient history like look at
this stuff all this might be blocked
down actually I'm not gonna say that's
at a one piece of stone but there like
this right here I forgot what this uh
site is called but yeah carved right out
the side of a mountain amazing
absolutely amazing so yeah as you can
see this place is on my
list spectacular let's see here okay
let's see we got Josh LeBlanc think
there's a connection with the UAP
phenomenon in Los Angeles civilization
yes I do I'm I'm leaning in that
direction for sure if you want me to
tell the truth um and all I can do is
say the truth
um when it comes to these uaps man like
this stuff goes throughout history even
um Christopher Columbus had described
this Red Orb that followed them for a
period of time when they were crossing
the Atlantic um there's been some weird
stuff that has been said over over
history about these these these things
um and I'm wondering if it's humans if
it's us or our creators or whatever just
documenting us but they've been around I
I I tell people they're like oh you know
do you think aliens could have done this
and I'm like we are aliens I think that
we're a mixed species this is something
that not everyone agrees upon but
something just seems that we as humans
don't assimilate with our environment
like all the other insects and animals
of the planet right we leave a big
stain it's almost like we don't belong
here not everyone's going to agree with
me on that leave a comment share your
disdain um let's see
here second I'm G to make sure I don't
miss got
that okay I got all the super chats
leave other any other comments let's see
Jimmy I'm tourist you think India hold
some secrets to advance ancient
civilizations well I will say some of
the most sophisticated uh relics of
ancient civilizations some of the stuff
I just showed you like their stonework
is mind B so I gota I gotta cover that
in a comprehensive video so stay tuned
for that India is the one thing I
haven't covered yet and you know I've
been so big on Egypt Atlantis you know
South breu po polygonal Stone uh
stonework throughout the continents but
like India is the one thing I haven't
touched on
yet let's see
here I am curious about your other
thoughts on like that big ass truck and
all these uh thousand tons Stones it's
like how do they do it like if they're
gonna say that we move this stuff
on on logs what log is gonna support two
million pounds such as that ramum
statue I need to see that and I'd like
to see that two million pounds being
lifted on and off of it too by the way I
just need to see that as well I need to
see they're like well Egyptians probably
had barges what
barge bar doesn't mean they didn't right
I wasn't there but like they left
absolutely no explanation for that not
not of stones of this weight in
magnitude for that matter and some
people will just discount like well they
just scaled it up if they did some they
could have done bigger and I'm like that
doesn't make sense at a certain level
when you're going in the range of
hundreds of tons it becomes a whole
different animal and then when you get
up to a thousand tons this is what I
call stupid weight it's so heavy that
it's dumb you could have impressed me if
you done half the weight kind of a thing
500 tons is impressive enough to blow my
mind but a thousand tons is just so next
level it's like why why how so yeah
let's see here Sound Vibrations I'm open
to that everything's a frequency so they
found a way to harness it that could be
the
Lost ancient technology that we've been
looking for but it's like what does that
look
like come on guys keep going with these
questions this is
fun see here how far is
on okay all right what about Indonesia
the oldest pyramid is there oh yeah
gadang I always say that incorrectly
yeah that's pretty wild site I know
Graham Hancock touched on it in ancient
apocalypse there is a cavity down in
there that has been dated to over 20,000
years old all the academic Skeptics and
say there it's just a you know volcanic
tube or whatever you know lava tube I'm
like have you investigated have you have
you excavated it
no stick some cameras down there let's
investigate let's do a you know a you
know a um excavation of it there's so
many unknowns to it we don't know what's
in that cavity down below ground pedit
Shing radar has identified a cavity and
dating when they've gone down to take
samples the further they go down the
older it gets and so to me that site
needs more investigation and at this
point anything that the so-called powers
of be are try to take your mind from
just makes me want to look into even
more yeah so beef F said I just learned
about Chinese pyramids any chance you go
to take a look yeah so I've covered this
uh briefly what was one of my prior
videos or maybe it's on social media
I've been covering it but a lot of
people don't realize that there are
unbelievably impressive pyramids in
China and China is as mysterious as it
gets right and their lost history is
something else like you know thousands
of years ago they cut themselves off
from the rest of the world and they went
from being this very generous outgoing
culture to something happened and they
just cut everything off it's very
interesting um was Dynasty which I don't
want to speak right now but um it was
one of them a while back but they just
completely closed themselves off from
the world very interesting stuff there
but that's the thing why are there
pyramids in China and I should bring up
some pictures here but um let's
see let's
see all right come on guys keep coming
with them questions or I'll go back to
showing you slides of this awesome
stonework let's see
[Music]
here all
right let's keep it up on both chats I
want to give love all the way
around Rumble all right got a good
amount of people watching
here all right they got us on the
homepage how cool is that so to anyone
just tuning in I've been covering ing my
recent video where I talked about the
Egyptians moving 1,000 ton Stones
hundreds of miles 720 ton Stones 400
miles um and this just far exceeds the
known capabilities of the Egyptians if
you haven't seen my recent video on this
should be at the top of my feed go check
it out you not follow me on Twitter and
Instagram do that as well so you can
keep up to date um because those videos
didn't get as many views as they
normally do uh which is interesting but
um so let's see
here yeah pyramid in Bosnia so guys I've
really looked into that and it's just
not I'm not saying there isn't ancient
stuff there I'm not saying that's not
the case but as far as being a pyramid
if you look at it from the other side
it's really just looks like a mountain
um I've looked into this I it's a very
touchy subject because I see people just
passionately go and and support that
it's a pyramid but look Graham Hancock
went there and he very politely told
others that it's like nah it just wasn't
maybe there's stuff there but he thought
that it wasn't what it was being
portrayed as I'll leave it at that I
haven't been there myself so I I
shouldn't speak too hard on it right um
let's see
here okay M thank you again she said
have you heard of the Sphinx or Romania
or the
horio in trans Silva SAA this force was
named the most haunted force in the
world youfo show up there no I'm going
to have to look into that I I'm not
familiar to be honest with you on that
one
uh let's see commentary 101 thank you so
much it's very G are you people being
sacrificed to the sky Gods AKA UFOs are
people being sacrificed you know I'm
gonna go with no I don't feel okay this
is this is where it gets complicated
because are a ton of people that go
missing every year right I just assume
they're getting sold into sex slavery or
that there's just a whole bunch of
serial killers out there more than we
realize still doing their thing uh I
think that
if it were the case that UFOs coming in
they'd be indiscriminately just
snatching
people and so I think it'd be more
parent it's possible it's possible but
I'm just not so sure that's what's going
on I just don't I don't want to believe
that right I don't know I feel like
there'd be more stuff going on I feel
like we' there's so many billions of us
now right and so many of us have these
cell phones and cameras and security
systems and ring cameras and everything
else if they're going to be adducting
people it's got to be in the middle of
the woods while they're camping right so
that being said there are these missing
people if you've seen the The Missing
um is it Paul C cads or I'm Miss
pronouncing his name but he's talked
about this in depth and there are some
weird stories of people going totally
just Vanishing Without a Trace in
National Parks throughout the United
States and a few of the cases I thought
were I don't know if that's that
convincing but a few of the other cases
I saw was like oh this is weird
anything's possible um Pebble Trader
said modern river barges can carry 2700
tons doesn't it seem more likely that uh
they went that route than carry over
land and mountains aam Razer yes I would
say that by the by sheer logic it would
make sense to carry a thousand tons on
the river but the question becomes is
what evidence is there that the
Egyptians of you know 30 you know 3,000
plus years ago at the time that these
monuments were constructed involving the
the ram see them um what evidence is
that the Egyptians could carry anything
even remotely that heavy um the largest
stone boats or excuse me largest boats
ever uh found from ancient Egypt canot
support
Stones there is evidence that they did
carry smaller limestones um but when
we're talking in the realm of a thousand
tons even though we could do that in
modern times I don't know what
capability the Egyptians could have
possibly have had to finagle that stones
of that weight on and off anything and
What boat they could possibly crate that
could handle that kind of weight I don't
know like but it's possible I'm not
going to say it's not possible it's just
that really need to see a demonstration
and a number of years ago they they did
a demonstration where they moved some
block that was like two and a half tons
I think flipped over I'll also say this
that if the Egyptians had brought
countless stones on the Nile where are
the stone blocks at the bottom because
surely there would have been incidents
where things would have fallen over
there would have been accidents in
ancient times there should be plethora
of ancient stone blocks just bottom of
the Nile and they haven't found such
things which is
interesting um let's see
paides pides David pides yeah I
recommend that one that he had just a
few years ago um I watched one of his
documentaries on the Miss before one
it's pretty creepy in fun
way all right let's see
herey should share a bit of his
encounters the parano reals I sense he's
explor the as playing I've had some
bizarre synchronicities I haven't had
anything totally paranormal but I have
had I'll tell the story sometime it
wasn't like ghostly but I know people
are gonna yell at me for not finishing
the story
um I'll hold off on it because it's such
a special story and it ties into a
moment in my life when I needed a sign
so I'll save it I know you don't like
hearing me like get a start on the story
but not finishing it but it's just the
right moment to share it it just is um
looks like he smells really good today
thank you I showered and everything best
Channel on YouTube thank you um let me
filter between the comments here to see
what people are saying I want to
entertain some questions this video is
about the the video I had just made or
this live stream is about the video I
just made and I'm telling you I don't
know if you guys saw Tucker Carlson who
I deeply respect if you just people
don't like him I'm like you guys not
listening to what he's
saying he recently on two different
platforms one on the RO Rosanne bar
podcast as well as a speech he gave in
Las Vegas a few weeks ago he said he
said it is a known fact that there is
the we have no idea Egyptians
constructing pyramids and I'm like yes
somebody like him to say that out loud
is going to help the community grow for
other people like Boomers and be like oh
well I'm sure the Egyptians figured out
some way to do it it's like no like this
is far more of a mystery Than People
realize um so I'm happy to announce
speaking of rosan bar so I just went on
her podcast on Monday it I don't know
exactly when it's going to air maybe the
week next week or the week after uh they
have a few things lined up but I had an
hour and a half long podcast with
Roseanne Bar I this was so awesome man
we went full conspiracy we this is gonna
be mark my words there be hit pieces on
this like we went hard after some things
we talked about all kinds of different
stuff you guys GNA I think you guys are
really going to enjoy it I even guys I
made rosan bar laugh the butt off for a
minute there it was like a surreal
moment man she is her and her family is
so down to earth and so lovely it's
interesting meeting that's a a total
Legend someone that has so much
celebrity to them such a notable person
and then meeting them and seeing what
they're like in real life and I was just
blown away these are such smart sweet
loving people her and her whole family I
was just blown
away
um uh so let's see here let me look
through more of these comments we're
getting a good amount in here so said
Jimmy hook up with Luke rowski um from
weor change dude I met him at the same
event when I met Roseanne he was there
at the uh anest event in Phoenix that I
was just at he's a cool guy I met him at
Mar Lago when I had the opportunity to
go there as well and I was talking with
him and Ian Crossland and about doing
some sort of collab and going on a show
in Miami so I'll keep you guys posted on
that we're talking about that um all
right let's see here what other super
chats we got I don't want to miss any
here okay we got uh
am or excuse me amek 619 please
everything in the universe is
frequencies if there has to be something
there I want to know what you think
about that well it's just like Nicholas
Tesla said you know it's all about
frequency and vibration um the whole
universe is measured in frequency sound
even light is measured in hertz atoms
themselves are said to vibrate and be
held together by this Myster you know
mysterious force of energy that just
keeps rejuvenating itself that in itself
can be measured the frequency so I think
that this whole universe is one big
illusion in the best way possible it's
intelligent design and um what I'm
saying right now might be considered
future science to some people and that
like it'll be understood you know by
science in the future whereas right now
it sounds like conspiracy to some people
or just over the toop pseudo or whatever
but no it's real um let's see here real
quick people hit the smash the like
button if you haven't done so already
thank you so much feu 44 for that super
chat I appreciate it all right let's see
here what are the questions you guys
have see
here I gotta have an assistant here with
me to like help read these things
off but you guys are
awesome all
right
um let's
see
oh you guys are awesome okay looks like
we just got a huge Super Chat here oh
wow 50 bucks from JL hey Jimmy what do
you think about this guy's theory he has
put out a video showing how it's
possible to float Stones which seems
very video name is quote uh how did the
uh how were the pyramids of Egypt built
part one I feel like I've seen this let
me bring this up on my YouTube how were
the Pyramids built apart one and I'm
gonna like share screen this so we can
all take a look at it okay hold on one
second add to
Stage
boom all right so we're not gonna listen
to it but I'm gonna do like a brief skip
around to kind of give us an idea I want
to honor your Super Chat by looking into
this briefly this won't be doing it
justice because of skipping around and
not listening to everything but I want
to just see the gist of what he's
showing
here
oh wow okay so I'm already
intrigued one thing that goes to my mind
is like hey well I need to see that 720
ton stone and a th ton Stone being done
like that
right the now River was once eight miles
closer
uh to the pyramid than it is today so
that's worth mentioning went virtually
it went right up there so I love that
he's showing that oh this is
wild um I'd be curious to see what
mechanism they're showing for lifting um
what's causing the uh the floating
excuse me um obviously I have it hear it
so like we're missing key info here but
at at least want to entertain this
unique
Theory like River style or Canal Style
interesting oh wow so I don't know like
I'm already you know of course skeptical
I need to see things you know when
animation everything it's a great way of
pain how something's possible but I just
need to see things right that's how I
that's how my brain works this is pretty
cool um this is something I'm gonna have
to dive into more that is something new
to me um I briefly had saw this
somewhere but um
yeah I like it it's just that the first
thing that goes through my skeptical
brain is let's see it done with a
because that's what we're dealing with
now now it's not about like well how did
they do it for two three four five ton
stones in Egypt now it's like now I need
to see a thousand tons or nothing or
bust right it's like I need to see how
they did the biggest stuff and then we
can talk about the smallest stuff which
is the most Fair way to go about it um
let's see here oops see what else we got
um s coma have you heard of a team of
archaeologists who drilled at the foot
of the Spinx with a drill bit apparently
they hit Granite at a crazy so I am
familiar with what you're talking about
I don't know about them hitting Granite
but I know that they had drilled in
front of the Paw to explore for a ground
cavity and there's a cavity underneath
the Spinx Paws they say oh there's
nothing down there so don't worry about
it um oh by the way there was a followup
from JL another 50 very kind of you by
the way I'm a huge fan and have been for
years thanks for what you do JL you just
gave me 100 bucks that is so generous a
deal thank you so much for that that
means a lot in your kind words as well
um I'm back to seea yeah so there are
cavities under the Spinx zah says
there's nothing there a ground radar and
when they of course they had so they
drilled into it and sent cameras down
there but they never showed the public
what they saw they just said there was
nothing down there under there's some
groundw waterer I don't know about with
them hitting Granite pretty wild um but
I know that there's been studies of the
SPs where not everything has been shared
with the public that I do know which is
wild um let's see here what are the
questions you
here let me skip back and forth yeah
rumble's hooking up we got some good
views on here someone says you need to
work on your sound it's curently fuzzy
and clipping off that
sucks should be good on this mic go like
this how does it sound to everyone
else
how's the sound sounding people I'm
looking
on hit one if the sound is good hit two
if the sound is not good I'm gonna be
looking here sounds okay sounds fine you
can sound as bad bad not good not good
fuzzy sound is
scratchy better now one two oh it's all
over the place sounds
like that sucks okay well I'm going to
have to play around with my sound
capabilities here people that's
disappointing I wonder if it's because
this wire is touching
this that's frustrating all right I get
it it could be a lot
better show goes on I can't do anything
about it now um dark Fox 2000 good
evening Jimmy keep up the great work and
I like the PLS in the background I have
ones behind uh I have the ones your
right should thank you plants make a
house Vibe so much better it's the best
decorating you can do honestly it makes
the whole place feel alive it just does
something to the air as well I swear I
feel like it
purifies um let's see
here number 10 thank you so much if you
change the speed of the moon's orbit
would it cause massive flooding yeah our
tides are influenced more than anything
because of the Earth's or excuse me the
moon's um forces on it now if we did not
have a apparently the tides would be
twice as strong and twice as delayed or
something to that I might be messing
that up but the moon contributes to the
the tides that we have and which is
causes the most abundance of life in the
earth's ocean is dependent on the tides
um most of the Earth's um most of the
ocean uh life is dependent on the tides
of the Hast very stuff so without the
moon or if the moon changed in some way
yeah it would massively affect it either
for better or worse uh Nikki NADA said
Jimmy do you know any developments on
the scan pyramid project they found a
giant void like four years ago crickets
right I heard there was going to be a
big announcement I heard this just like
a couple months ago there was a big
announcement coming and then as far as I
know it's Cricket sent so I don't know
what's going on there I mean it's like
they find this huge void above the grand
Gallery essentially about the same size
of it I think we found a second Grand
Gallery um and then nothing I'm like I
don't believe for a second that they
would have gone in there and drilled and
cameras in through there Egypt shitty
like that guys like I feel like they are
so protective that if you find something
astonishing They're Gonna Keep it from
themselves or whatever I don't know it's
really discouraging actually H Nicki
NADA and study Bitcoin thank you so much
I almost feel like the Bitcoin thing you
know what I mean I don't know I feel
like I'm way late on that um see let me
double check on my oh who's this loser
say I let me banned hold on one second
one
second all right
gone I'm not gonna read that person's
comment that was even on Rumble
troll H that's
funny yeah I got rid of him
gone a troll that's funny B
forever all right let's see
here
second man that bumed me out about the
sound should be much better this
microphone is the microphone I use this
is my roads mic I use it on all my
videos perfect but streamyard and maybe
it's just the software that I'm
using all right I want to questions here
I'm just going to go for a little bit
longer here it's Friday evening got a
big weekend I hope uh to all of you that
celebrate Christmas Merry Christmas to
those of you who don't enjoy the day off
hopefully um or just enjoy some good
downtime unplug I'm gonna be working on
my next video I'm not going to share
exactly the topic what it is but the
timing is right on it I want it to be
provocative I intend to have it done
before the end of the year so I'm gonna
be hammering away at that getting
together with family for Christmas but
before and after I'm just be hammering
away I need to nail that out
what in a couple days so I need to nail
that out someone says your sound is
choppy and you're on YouTube in fix it
okay someone said if you're on YouTube
exit go back in the sounds fine that's
interesting Britney I don't know if
you're talking to
me but people said that the sound was
better when they went back into my
stream it's interesting yeah Merry
Christmas
everybody um yeah someone's asking how
could Egyptians move 500 plus T blocks
again I see people talking about moving
this stuff on water but hey how are you
moving a thousand tons on that bad boy
I'm not saying it's not possible we do
it today somebody did it back then but
really what my thesis if I had a thesis
is that being what we were taught about
in school about the ancient Egyptians
for how they moved any type of weight
there's no explanation for the how they
move stones of this magnitude not even
remotely close not even remotely and my
thesis is that there were things that
were done long ago that have since been
lost whether itats the Egyptians or
whatever it is that there is lost
history and the known tooling
capabilities of the dynasty Egyptians
that we were taught about this stuff far
exceeds them and again a lot of these
works a lot of people W even familiar
with a lot of so many people had never
heard of the Ramis statue many people
that follow my channel that follow the
the mysteries of the Ancients sure they
sure have but most people just walking
down the street like this stuff is just
new to them they haven't heard this
stuff at all
so uh let's see
here someone oh sorry I missed your your
Super Chat 199 do you think the empty
quarter desert is really empty what is
that the empty quarter desert i g have
to Google that um Rico said Jimmy have
you heard about the underwater pyramids
for Cuba I have and I think that it's
bunk so I looked into that now that was
like what a 2007 or whatever that was
that came out and the pictures went all
over the place that sonar image guys
apparently was so it's not what it looks
like I saw the original and I'm like I
don't see any pyramids I don't see
and I feel like if that was the case so
many other amateur people would have
gone down there thrown some a GoPro and
some camera and lobed it down I mean I
don't know I'm not saying it's not there
it's just that when I saw the original
scan I'm like this is the famous green
photo that you saw that went around
wasn't what it really looked like that
was completely like an artist rendition
very deceptive
so a total total bummer to be honest
with you Paul I live in rule Montana I
have personally witnessed uh something
from out of this world it's all real
they are here just wanted to say don't
leave us with that Paul you gotta keep
talking what did you see was it like
Bigfoot was it like an orb something
flying through the woods let me tell me
what my brother and his wife saw and
they're trustworthy people they don't
make up they're not storytellers um
this was a couple years ago they were
staying at an Airbnb cabin on the Mogan
Rim in Arizona and it was at dust and
they were hanging out on the patio
looking over you know the sky and they
saw what's that a glowing orb going
horizontal across the sky like a yellow
orangish and then they're looking at
like what the heck is that it stops goes
poof straight up outer space like in an
instant and they're like they never
could figure out what the hell that was
they know what they saw defy the laws of
physics just a right Ang
what was that the same thing that's been
described by so many other people an orb
that's like going and just shoots
off so is it a drone is
it top secret technology is it beings
amongst us what the hell is
it I need to see something myself to
really be certain but Mark Adam love
your work Jimmy hope you and your loved
ones have an amazing Christmas of last
New Year thank you so much it's very
nice of you to say Mark and I wish the
same to you and everyone else watching
listening right now that means a lot um
especially with how crazy the world is
now it's easy to get down a lot of
people need to spread more joy like
because we're witnessing all kinds of
crazy stuff happen in this world and
things are heading into an uncertain
path I am particularly concerned over
the next year that specifically the next
like 10 11
months I had one big prediction is that
the world will be different by then I
think the powers to be are fixed in to
do something crazy between now and the
next election we'll see I think everyone
needs to be vigilant and smart and be
paying attention to the world because
there are thing there are big things
happening I do believe that is the case
um what do you guys think's coming you
guys had to predict what's happening
what are know what's going to come into
the world in the near future I'd be
curious now in the next elections oh
yeah people bringing up the Colorado
Supreme Court oh my God that is gonna
get overturned it h it has to be this is
heading down an extremely dangerous dark
path can't keep going down this path
okay moo Super
Chat I would love to see the pyramids
with my own eyes one day is it sketchy
to visit no it's not Egypt is safe is
totally safe I've been there three times
now it is safe said don't go wandering
around the streets of Cairo by yourself
at night that would be smart sure as
hell wouldn't do that in most any City I
live in or I visit in the United States
now but visiting Egypt is unbelievably
safe the the Egyptian government takes
so serious like just to get in any hotel
you go it's like going through the
airport you go through a metal detector
and everything everything is locked down
the I felt unbelievably safe they have
Egyptian tourism police there with AK
keeping an eye on all the sites um egyp
tourism in Egypt is their number one
thing they need it they're dead serious
about keeping that place safe um years
since there's been a terrible incident
um I highly recommend Egypt you could
travel there affordably it's doable and
if you're thinking about going I'd
recommend going now pull the Trigg
tomorrow is not processed or processed
tomorrow is not promised and so it's
like get the same go get busy living or
get busy dying and to go there and see
these p with your own
eyes like the Great Pyramid of Giza at
its height was equivalent to a 47 story
building now it's like 43 44 stories
because the missing Capstone is is 30
feet smaller now so you're looking at
like a you know a 44 story building
today as it stands and you look at
you're like oh my God
like from the base of it to the to the
middle of the Capstone is 355t over 100
met because the base is 750 feet wide on
all four sides which means 755 feet wide
to one side of the other if you go to
the middle it's 350 feet basically from
where you stand at the base to the to
the top you can't even see it because
it's another it's just you know you're
looking at it was it 51 degrees or what
is it 26 degrees what am I talking about
and can't top of it um wild stuff it's
like it's a mustsee in person a
musty get off that couch and go as I say
um going on here thank you to everyone
tuning in from Rumble and on YouTube
looks like we got a pretty good turn
turnout on this Friday night look at
this look at all of us here this is wild
man I got twice as many people watching
un Rumble than I do on YouTube see this
what I'm talking about people wonder
like why I'm un Rumble it's like man
Rumble is real good to me they promote
my
stuff something to be said for that
isn't there um I'm grateful to YouTube
they've been real good to me as well but
like my my following I got less than
100,000 followers on Rumble and yet I
have double the live stream views than I
do on YouTube right now figure that out
see know what I'm saying people real
quick if you haven't already hit the
like button I guess you know maybe that
will stir something in the algorithm
right all you got to do is
press too hard um but I love you anyways
um let's see here I want to ask
questions JL you've been way too
generous got a new one coming in it's
been lifelong dream of mine to climb the
Great Pyramid I know they said it's not
allowed now but is there any way I could
talk to someone and get permission for
magician authorities I just have to do
it it's on my list okay brother I feel
the same way and I've looked into this
they won't they just won't they it used
to be something doable now they're so
serious about it that they will throw
you in prison the max they'll throw you
in a Cairo jail for up to 30 days and
find you 100,000 Egyptian
pounds a few years ago when I was there
that was equivalent to about
$4,000 um now because the Egyptian pound
has fallen it's like the last looked it'
be like
$3200 brother it's highly likely you'll
get caught you may even get injured
while doing it people have died trying
to find that thing um and although I
feel the same like I really want to
climb it I have that spiritual calling I
really really really want to do it but
like they won't Grant you permission
they just won't they're not doing it for
anybody anymore and if they are on some
DL thing huge amount of money to some
cool kid you know celebrity or something
and even then I don't think they it um I
would say don't it's not worse going to
a Cairo jail man I there was a YouTuber
that did this okay so looking to that
guy who was that prankster guy
um he was like like
Russian
um what's his
name I'm forgetting it forgive me but he
did this like a year or two ago and he
got caught he knew he was getting caught
he just ran up and did in front of
everybody in broad daylight and bro they
threw him in jail for a solid week he
said it was one of the worst experiences
of his whole life he crapped himself the
whole time because they gave him spoiled
whatever or dirty water whatever the
problem was us if you're if you're an
American you know your belly can't
tolerate some Cairo unfiltered water um
I don't know man I feel the same way I'd
like to go do it I just don't know if
the conse the consequence is worth it
that's only you could decide only you
could decide that one um let's see here
I want to go for a few more minutes I'm
getting a little tired um it's been a
big big week we got a big big weekend in
front of us um oh my God Paul 100 bucks
holy crap we are definitely in a
spiritual war it's about to show itself
I hope all
brother I could not agree more this is
we're living in spiritual warfare we are
living in a times of good versus evil
this was written about in scripture
thousands of years ago hold on I'm not
some Bible but I'm like guys there are
there is a difference between good and
evil right vers wrong true and false and
it's like history is repeating itself
it's like we're living in a time where
everything is upside down we're like
lawlessness and and and is being
commended and and Truth is being
censored and people that are doing the
right thing and speaking up are being
persecuted this is backwards this is not
supposed to be like this and more and
more people I talk to feel the same way
that this is something there is a battle
of good versus evil happening and I'm a
believer I'm a Believer in a in the most
high I don't like to use the word God
because it has a to a lot of people they
don't like
that it has a certain notion to it I'm
like I'm talking about the most high the
source of all that is the grand Creator
whatever you want to call it I believe
we part of something incredibly special
and that our lifetime maybe it's a test
I don't know exactly what this is but
it's special I don't believe that we're
part of a
primordial of chemicals and heat and and
and moisture coming together no like
this is love goes beyond that um and it
doesn't make sense and so I'm with you
like people need to armor
themselves um with not just love that
sounds cheesy but like awareness people
need to be paying attention more than
ever
there are there are bad things that are
fo if you if you agree if you if you if
that resonates with you leave a comment
and support Paul right now Paul thank
you for supporting me and out of all
comments to make I really really that
was I feel like this is what people need
to hear um JL again man you are so
generous um you were in the service like
me I was CB maybe right on um and I had
someone in my Battalion go to the
Japanese prison and they literally spent
days in there and they have PTSD from it
so yeah I can only imagine what Kyo Jill
is like oh my God that sounds awful what
happened to the don't leave another
Super Chat you're too generous like what
happened were they were raped did they
get crap beat out of them someone like
me would not do well in jail I'm just
too much of a pretty boy looking skinny
little white guy right like I'd get
prayed upon in some for jail they would
split me in
half and you know how it would be
horrendous someone like me because I'm a
fighter I'd fight back it's just in my
instinct like someone pushes me HT and
so i' kill they curb stomp me oh it'd be
the worst thing ever oh it'd be so bad
I'd have to join a gang just to survive
and have to do them favors oh that'd be
horrendous not funny not funny um yeah I
want to see what these comments are
involving what people uh if they they
resonate with what Paul was saying
involved us being in a spiritual war
right now because I couldn't agree more
I really I really couldn't agree
more see what people are saying yeah
good job Paul yeah people are commending
them I can agree more um real quick to
those of you who haven't seen the video
that this live stream is mostly about go
watch the video after this live stream
it's 13 minutes long most recent video
on Rumble and my most recent video on
YouTube minus I made a little brief clip
of it it's worth your time 13 minutes
it's got less than a quarter million
views which is low for me but the the
thumbs up on it were particularly high
like I know like I have a gauge now of
like kind of like the bearing of like
okay this many views if it has this many
likes I know it's a really good one and
anything less I'm like okay it's here
this one was particularly high but USS
as some of my other videos and I know
it's worth your time it really paints a
picture of just how mysterious works of
the ancient egyptions are when they move
such massive Stones because I put it
into comparison for how we do these
things today so if you're just tuning in
and you haven't seen that 13-minute
video I assure you it's worth your time
you learn something from it it it's
something that I made that I know could
be shared with others to be like this is
mystory people will really really go in
on debates they built the pyramids and
moved two and a
half fair play this takes things to a
whole other level which
raises about physics we're talking T
ston definitely check it out let me get
chat over here let me scroll back over
to
YouTube um Kana if I said that correctly
have you ever heard of Jessy Lee
Peterson I don't want to say no let me
just do a double on Google
Peterson American radio
host I don't know if I know
him check him
out all right conservative right on see
him up his
Instagram I'm gonna have to listen to
him I feel like I'm not familiar with
them but since you brought them up maybe
that's a calling and I need to check
them out I'll check them out thank you
for the
recommendation um see someone said
adjust your mic please okay so what's it
sounding like
and I'm gonna be wrapping this up for
aoup
minutes I wonder if it's because it'sing
that is that better now for a second May
it's the wires are touching it's so
frustrating guys I've had a lot of mic
I've gone through multiple mics trying
to make these live streams work and I
need to upgrade the
whole set here I need to get a whole
external thing going
on oh my God keeps coming in
out
out yeah okay someone said it sounds
good to me someone says there's back
feed for the mic adjust your Noise
Gate it sounds like your mic is under
fuzzy
shirt hold
on is this better does this help at all
so mixed so many people are saying it
sounds good to me it sounds like a bad
connection or slow internet it's not the
slow internet I'm plugged into the
router and this is gigabit
I oh know I'm so sorry how
frustrating JL says it's
terrible sell you're only fed fish heads
with rice by the way anyone getting
caught up J's talking about his buddy in
the service that went to a Tokyo for 60
days um you sleep concrete and in a
wooden chair all day long face forward
hands on knees and they will fire
you just for looking
around oh my God no wonder Japan has
such low crime rate right like they have
like no there's hardly any murders and
violent crime it's super low there for
how dense their population is dude that
sounds horrendous I'd be curious to know
what he did to get 60 days in their jail
oh my God you imagine all day long
that's real Chinese torture even though
they're Japan but like Chinese torture
thing it's like little things to just
torture the hell out of somebody so just
sit there straight with your hands on
your knees all day long don't look
around see at least an American prison
you could just Mo up and talk to people
you know if you're in solitary
confinement that's torture in itself but
most jails people just socialize the
whole day long but to be just no oh my
God someone said now the sound is bad
okay guys I'm gonna wrap it up this
sound thing is bothering me that breaks
my heart this is a shame because I got
so many awesome super chats coming in
guys sorry about the sound thing I'll
get this worked out for next time uh
it'll be a couple weeks before my next
live stream but in the meantime stay
tuned for my next video be done before
the new year least that's the plan
should be a good one um thank you guys
all for your support I hope you guys
have a lovely Christmas stay tuned if
you're not following me on Twitter I
highly recommend you do so follow me on
locals by the way support me on locals
I'll be doing a Q&A exclusive to all
paid supporters locals before the end of
the year I'll be I do them every month
on so check that out um but let's see
here yeah thank you guys so much you all
have a great night thank you for your
time sorry about the audio issues this
was a lot of fun uh we'll do it again
soon but stay tuned for my next video
and to those of you that haven't watched
my most recent video the 13 minute one
involving the moving of you know
thousand ton Stones check it out with
all that said here guys I love you and
I'll see you again soon bye now